officiellement à la chambre des
communes auprès de la communauté
des cadeaux italiennes.
- Quand mon père est venu
de l'Italie en 1934...
- Dans la petite Italie
à Montréal, Nicolas DiPietro
prend une marche,
avec ses souvenirs.
- On ne peut pas condamner
des gens même parce qu'ils ont
l'apparence italienne,
imaginez-vous!
- L'usine de soulier La Joconde
appartenait à sa famille et
elle chaussait la royauté
confisquée par le gouvernement
fédéral, à l'aube de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Le 10 juin 1940, le Canada
déclare la guerre à l'Italie
de Benito Mussolini.
Ottawa ordonne alors
l'arrestation de Canadiens
d'origine italienne, de crainte
qu'ils ne soient des saboteurs
ou des espions.
Pour le père et l'oncle
de Nic DiPietro, c'est un long
calvaire qui commence.
- Une série d'autobus et
de paddy wagon se sont enlignés
ici, la GRC rentre dans
la bâtisse et annonce d'arrêter
toute production. Tout le monde
était un peu effrayé et confus,
certains disaient : avez-vous
des mandats? Les gens qui
passaient voyaient toute cette
foule-là et ils se faisaient
dire : "Ah, c'est des Italiens
qui viennent de se faire arrêter
à cause de la guerre. Ah, vous
devriez les fusiller, toute!"
Je me suis dit : quelle peur
ils ont dû avoir!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Près de 600 Italo-Canadiens
sont arrachés à leur famille
et emprisonnés dans des camps
d'internement à Kananaskis,
Petawawa ou Fredericton.
- En fait, ça ici, c'est
la photo de mon grand-père
lorsqu'il était au camp
d'internement. En tout et
partout, il a passé environ
deux ans à Petawawa et un an et
quelque à Fredericton.
- Un sujet tabou dans
la famille. James a grandi
sans connaître cette histoire.
Sa mère a gardé le secret
presque toute sa vie même quand
il lui a annoncé qu'il voulait
devenir agent de la GRC.
JAMES MALIZIA, petit-fils
de Nicola Doganieri
- C'est clair, il y avait
une honte. Je suis certain qu'il
y avait une colère également.
- Mais l'histoire permet parfois
de boucler la boucle.
En 2012, il devient responsable
de la sécurité nationale
à la GRC et il a une pensée
pour son grand-père.
- Si j'étais vivant à l'époque,
j'aurais occupé le poste
qui aurait été responsable
de cette opération, incluant
l'arrestation de mon grand-père.
- Des vies chamboulées,
des années volées,
une injustice qu'Ottawa
veut corriger, avec des excuses
officielles. Un geste
qui n'est pas sans
susciter la controverse.
ROBERTO PERRIN, historien
- Le fascisme existait au Canada
dans les communauté italiennes.
Je crois que le gouvernement
veut présenter des excuses tout
court sans faire la distinction
entre ceux qui étaient coupables
et ceux qui ne l'étaient pas.
DAVID LAMETTI, ministre
de la Justice du Canada
- Je réponds en tant que
ministre de la Justice
en regardant en arrière,
il n'y avait pas d'accusation
criminelle, il n'y avait
aucune conviction.
- Pour le premier ministre
de la Justice d'origine
italienne, le moment
est plus que symbolique.
- Personnellement, pour moi
aussi, ce sera très émouvant
et je vais essayer
de garder les yeux secs.
- C'est une forme de rédemption,
de justice.
- Soulagé, heureux,
ayant vu la fin
d'un cercle assez long et
triste.
- Un baume teinté de regret,
pour son père mort il y a 4 ans.
- Ça aurait été, je crois,
chic s'il avait vu ça se faire.
- Pour les victimes aujourd'hui
disparues, l'injustice
est impossible à réparer.